bonjour et bienvenue dans ce récap
critique 2019 des films que j'ai bien
aimé cette année l'année dernière
c'était la première fois que je faisais
ça c'est un petit peu brouillon il y
avait beaucoup de j'aime bien pas très
constructif
donc je vais essayer de faire un petit
peu mieux cette année j'ai vu environ
130 films qui sont sortis en 2019 et
donc parmi ceux là j'en ai sélectionné
10 il me semble qu'ils montrent
particulièrement plu qui sont dans le
top du top de ce que j'ai aimé un qui
est un petit peu moins mais dont j'avais
envie de parler aussi
et avant de le mettre à parler de cinéma
juste donc en novembre là j'ai sorti la
vidéo jean teulé mbada sur amelia
earhart avant ça elle est à moi et j'ai
pas vraiment reparler de taiwan sur
cette chaîne depuis donc merci beaucoup
à tous les gens qui m'aiment et hamoir
aps
si vous n'avez pas aimé savoir que
c'était parce que vous l'avez pas vu du
coût regarder si vous n'avez pas aimé du
tout bas c'est pas grave c'est la vie
mais j'ai eu énormément de retours
positifs et ça fait très plaisir pour le
reste de l'équipe aussi si vous avez
contribué à thé noir et que vous
attendez de contrepartie on ne vous
oublie pas elles arriveront c'est juste
que certaines contreparties nécessite le
dvd de la série et pour ça il faut qu'on
termine le making-of et c'est pas encore
le cas donc ça sortira pas des contre
parties arriveront un jour c'est certain
c'est absolument certain mais juste
faudra encore un petit peu de patience
et je vous tiendrai au courant
voilà maintenant sans plus attendre
parlons cinéma le premier film dont je
voulais parler c'est l'heure de la
sortie réalisée par sébastien marnier
avec laurent lafitte
c'est un film que j'ai vu en tout début
d'année dernière que j'ai eu l'occasion
de revoir une fois depuis depuis par
d'autres sans belge et donc c'est un
petit peu étayés mon avis c'est un film
qui se passe dans un lycée en france un
film français y ait beaucoup de films
français dans cette liste et dans une
classe d'élèves doués en gros on a
rassemblé tous les meilleurs élèves du
lycée et on les a mis dans une place on
va voir c'est pas forcément une bonne
idée
au tout début du film le professeur
principal de cette classe se suicide en
plein milieu de la classe ce qui
installe une bonne ambiance entre les
élèves et donc laurent lafitte et est un
remplaçant qui arrive pour remplacer le
prof qui ne peut plus exercer ses cours
puisqu'il est mort et dans cette classe
et une ambiance très bizarre notamment
entre groupes d'élèves qui est vraiment
surdoué et qui est un peu malsain du
coup faille et l'ambiance malsaine qui
s'installe de plus en plus qui accentué
par le fait que c'est la canicule
pendant tout le film
donc c'est bien ce que souvent
l'ambiance pesante elle vient de du
froid de la grisaille par l'annoncé la
chaleur étouffante qu'on ressent pendant
tout le film et c'est ça besoin de plus
en plus bizarre parfois un peu trop à
mon goût mais c'était intéressant et ça
m'a un peu fait penser à un village des
damnés et c'est ça met en doute le film
avec les enfants qui ont les cheveux
gris les yeux rouges qui sont très
intelligents qui font flipper je crois
que c'est ça c'était c'était intéressant
franchement une bonne découverte et les
enfants jeux très bien où les adultes
aussi
le deuxième film dont je voulais parler
et une intime conviction
ah j'ai pas fait de catégorie cette fois
à la première c'était dans la catégorie
show et le deuxième dans la catégorie
justice et une intime conviction c'est
donc un film de antoine rambaut n'est
pas poète et c'est eu un film qui traite
du procès jacques viguier donc d'une
histoire vraie d'un homme qui est accusé
d'avoir tué sa femme sauf qu'on a aucune
preuve ya rien a juste disparu et n'a
pas de corps et donc il est joué par
notamment marina foïs et olivier gourmet
oui mon ordinateur se trouve ici avec
mes dates et d'ailleurs
et quand veille non merci donc c'est un
film sur ce deuxième procès puisque au
premier procès jacques viguier est
innocent sauter puis à lui un procès en
appel est donc le film suit le
personnage de marina foïs qui elle est
un personnage fictif la fois proche de
la famille est très impliqué très
investi dans la sphère elle veut
vraiment prouver l'innocence de jacques
viguier et c'est pour ça qu'elle va
qu'elle
elle convainc eric dupond moretti quand
avocat qui lui existe de reprendre la
sphère et de défendre jacqueville donc
on suit ce duo entre marina foïs qui se
retrouve de plus en plus impliqué dans
la sphère alors qu'elle n'a rien à faire
là à la base et olivier gourmet qui joue
très très bien et notamment il ya un
plaidoyer à la fin qui est beau et je
sais pas pourquoi mais j'aime les
plaidoyers et donc c'était beau et c'est
intéressant aussi sur la justice sur la
présomption d'innocence sur sur
l'acharnement judiciaire l'acharnement
de certaines personnes des fois qu'ils
disent oui et des coupables forcément
séduit coupable et pas toujours ce qui
fait que j'ai apprécié ce film
troisième film de cette catégorie on est
toujours sûr du film français et on va
le rester encore un peu
les films ne sont pas forcément dans
l'ordre de sortie des films sont dans un
ordre qui n'a aucun ordre le troisième
film dont je parle et c'est dans la
catégorie sous marin le champ du loup
que peut-être vous avez vu parce qu'on
en a assez régulièrement en dit du bien
de ce film sur internet d'un film
d'antoine beaudry avec beaucoup
d'acteurs dont françois civil qu'on a vu
un peu partout au cinéma cette année
omar sy mathieu kassovitz et reda kateb
et d'autres personnes dont je n'ai pas
retenu le nom est donc le film se passe
dans le milieu des sous-marins français
dans un dans le cadre est fictif les
conflits qui sont abordés dans ce film
sont fictifs je crois que c'est un
conflit entre la russie et la finlande
et d'autres trucs mais ça pose un cadre
festif mais ça aborde des vrais
problèmes des vraies questions qui
pourraient survenir dans le cadre d'un
conflit et et si on avait un sous marin
nucléaire français se retrouver dans la
partie
en gros voilà on suit ces histoires de
sous marins et et on a une situation qui
se met en place qui est vraiment
merdique et qui pourrait arriver et
c'est très prenant vraiment le film il y
avait de la tension
je les ai vus je crois que trois fois au
cinéma et dont une fois avec mon père
est un moment il voulait aller aux
toilettes et il disait mais il va se
passer des trucs encore là il dit en
grand le tranquille parce que moi je
veux aller aux toilettes mais je veux
pas je veux pas perdre ce qui va se
passer et tu fais me l'a pas dit sur ce
ton là parce qu'il parle pas comme ça à
mon père mais voilà pour vous dire que
c'était prenant coup que papa tu vois
cette vidéo et et voilà voilà
du coup c'était bien regarder ce film
vraiment un très bon film français dans
la catégorie documentaire nous arrivons
à présent sur un film que je pense vous
n'avez pas vu peut-être vous ne verrez
jamais ou pas je sais pas s'il va sortir
donc je vais d'abord vous présenter ce
document tel ensuite vous expliquer
pourquoi il décide peut diffuser je
pense que c'est la meilleure chose
donc il s'agit de zénon l'a soumis qu'un
documentaire réalisé par françoise des
vies en partenariat avec avec le maison
des amis de marguerite de marguerite
yourcenar qui se trouve dans le nord je
sais plus le nom exact
en gros c'est un film qui retrace
l'adaptation au cinéma de l'oeuvre au
noir de marguerite yourcenar par andré
delvaux en 1988
oui ça peut paraître très obscur mais en
fait c'était génial c'est si vous aimez
le cinéma
si vous aimez le moyen âge si vous aimez
mais documentaire tout simplement pour
toutes ces raisons c'est un très bon
documentaire parce que on y retrouve à
la fois des éléments de l'histoire de
l'oeuvre au noir donc il ya un livre qui
se passe au 16e siècle
le san luis pozo xvième siècle donc en
pleine guerre religieuse et en suisse ce
personnage de zénon qui est un médecin
un peu en avance sur son temps
complètement il est trop intelligent il
dit des choses trop trop en avance sur
son temps et il est inquiété pour ça et
donc c'est un très bon livre déjà que
j'avais lu l'année dernière et que j'ai
beaucoup aimé et le documentaire parle à
la fois de ce livre et du des conditions
de l'adaptation 1988 donc on y retrouve
à la fois des reconstitutions des
changes entre marguerite yourcenar et le
réalisateur puisqu'ils ont beaucoup
échangé au début n'était pas du tout
chaud pour ce projet puis au fur et à
mesure elle était plus en plus investi
on voit aussi des interviews d'anciens
acteurs on voit comment l'acteur
principal qui était vraiment super beau
apparemment moi j'ai pas vu le film je
suis le documentaire comment il s'est
mis dans le personnage parce que c'est
pas un personnage facile quand même on a
des images du film on a des
reconstitutions on a un troisième saison
qui n'est ni l'acteur du film ni le nom
du livre aucun un autre acteur qui joue
zénon et qui se baladent sur les lieux
de tournage du film et c'était vraiment
une super ambiance far
ouais je sais je ne peux pas l'expliquer
autrement j'avais fait un très bon à
l'époque sur twitter quand après avoir
vu le film et peut-être que je mettrais
bien en en description du coût de ce
fait qu il y aborde peut-être d'autres
choses que j'oublie maintenant mais
c'était très beau et j'ai eu la chance
de le voir parce que ben l'oncle sam
s'il a été réalisée dans en or la
réalisatrice est belge il me semble ce
que le film se passe en partie à bruges
et et du coup il a été projeté une fois
dans un cinéma à bailleul c'était la
première projection en présence de la
réalisatrice était la première fois qu
elle même vous voyez le résultat qu'il
était probablement pas le résultat final
est donc c'était une projection suivie
d'un petit une discussion avec la
réalisatrice et du coup c'était super
intéressant et à terme elle disait
qu'elle voulait le projeter dans des
festivals et tout ça mais je sais pas où
le documentaire en est actuellement
donc si vous avez l'occasion de le voir
que mon ma description vous a mis l'eau
à la bouche j'ai regardé le parce que
c'était bien vraiment cinquième film
dans la catégorie québec et je ne vais
pas prendre cet axe en plus longtemps
c'était la femme de mon frère de monia
chokri avec l amener lisabeth bosser
dans leur principal super l'actrice que
j'ai découvert dans ce film qui jouais
vraiment super bien donc c'est un film
très très très drôle très bien écrit les
dialogues sont super intelligent et donc
c'est l'histoire d'une femme qui a la
trentaine qui a un doctorat mais dans un
domaine obscures qui ne trouvent pas de
poste à la sortie de ce doctorat qui est
un peu paumé dans sa vie aussi bien
senti mentalement que que que tout le
reste et les paumés le début du film
c'est qu'en gros elle se fait avorter
par une gynéco qui ensuite sort avec son
frère et ensuite il se passe plein de
trucs mais vraiment c'est sont les
dialogues qui font la force de ce film
des dialogues et les situations mais
c'était vraiment super bien écrit et
super bien joué entre donc l'actrice
principale et son frère et tous les
autres persos ils ont des parents
complètement aux phoques
je pense pas avoir besoin d'en dire plus
sur ce film parce que ce part un peu
dans tous les sens mais ça reste fasse
pas de la pure eux c'est juste bien
écrit et regardez regardez la femme de
mon frère parce que j'étais super bien
dans la catégorie de l'espace on arrive
enfin sur un film américain ou anglais
date anglais james craig james gray qui
est réalisateur et qui avait réalisé
avant de lost city of z ont dès lors ce
titi au physique je ne suis pas sûre et
et qui était un film que j'avais
beaucoup aimé et donc là cette année il
a réalisé hadas train avec brad pitt et
tommy lee jones est ce que j'ai aimé
dans ce film c'est une mise en scène du
d'un futur dans lequel on va dans
l'espace mais qui était à la fois
original et réaliste avec par exemple
bas le vaisseau qui fait les voyages
réguliers de la terre à la lune et la
base lunaire et ouais je sais pas
comment dire mais ça paraissait quelque
chose qui pourrait arriver si on en
arrive à un stade où on va dans l'espace
et non pas où on craint de la planète
mais c'était c'était un futur à qui
paraissait probable plausible et en même
temps donc on suit cette histoire de
brad pitt qui doit aller retrouver son
père qui est mort apparemment mais
peut-être pas c'est pas trop on l'envoie
en mission
d'abord juste pour envoyer un message à
son père depuis mars et on s'est dit
c'est pas trop où ça va le mener quoi
donc c'est un personnage qui en quête de
son père mais c'est aussi
c'est une belle histoire death and
espaces sont très bien cette dans la
dans la navette qui a lancé un appel au
secours celle sur la lune avec une
poursuite et plein de belles scènes dos
des scènes finales dans le spacieux mais
là je n'en dis pas plus un beau film
encore une fois regardez à d'astra je ne
sais plus à combien de films on en est
et ce n'est pas grave on en arrive à
papicha qui est lui est un film algérien
mais de mounia meddour l'actrice
principale et linak coudry et c'est un
film qui parle des violences envers les
femmes dans les années 90 en algérie
enfin les femmes envers des personnes
qui n'étaient pas assez religieuse donc
là c'était les femmes qui refusait de
porter le voile en vo on l'appelle cette
période la décennie noire
je connais pas énormément ce sujet et je
ne savais pas trop dans quoi je
m'embarquais en allant voir le film
d'ailleurs papicha ça veut dire jeune
fille apparemment et donc ça on suit le
parcours de jeunes filles qui sont
étudiantes en algérie dans les années 90
l'une d'elle l'actrice principale
personnage principal devait être
styliste plus tard et à bas l design pas
dévoile un design des robes et du coup
ça marche pas et et on voit la montée de
la violence
les menaces d'abord puis on se prend par
moments vraiment une bonne dose de
violence dans la gueule et très réaliste
et même pas à complètement montré non
plus on n'est pas dans du gore du tout
mais mais la mise en scène fait que
c'est vraiment
parfois inattendus quoi et du coup ça
nous prend aux tripes et c'était très
très bien joué tout les toutes les
actrices je jouais très bien et voilà un
film sur des faits réels mais pas dans
l'espace mais on est sur quelque chose
qui s'est réellement passé
et du coup je pense que c'est un film
important à voir le suivant d'ailleurs
ce sera aussi un film important à voir
donc papicha à voir dans le film suivant
on est aussi dans la catégorie violence
du coup un petit petit leitmotiv qui
apparaît avec de futurs guides de george
tillman junior avec amandla stenberg en
actrice principale
je parle de fétus livre j'aurais aussi
pu parler des misérables ces deux films
dont qui figurent dans le top de ma
liste de films vus cette année mais
comme il traite à peu près des mêmes
sujets genre de choisir un seul pouvoir
luminosité à 9
c'est le soleil comme ces deux films qui
parlent à peu près du même sujet j'en ai
choisi un seul sur les deux hommes
devaient étudier est un film qui parle
des violences policières envers les
noirs aux états unis les misérables est
un film qui parle des violences
policières envers les personnes de
banlieues en france il ya un petit nerf
du cou aller voir les misérables déjà un
mais j'ai aussi vous parler de vrai tu
livres puisque ces juges dans ce temps
là c'est un film qui parle qui suivent
parcours d'une famille noire a notamment
d'une jeune fille qui se retrouve
impliqué dans un cas de violences
policières
je peux rentrer dans les détails et 7
cette affaire là entraîne une montée de
violence dans ce quartier une au t2 de
questions aussi en elle même parce que
elle est témoin de quelque chose
est-ce qu'elle va ce qu'elle veut
témoigner donc se mettre en avant alors
qu'on vient toujours du expliqué qu'il
valait mieux pas se mettre en avant
qu'il fallait faire profil bas parce que
parce que la vie est comme ça et parce
que sinon ça risque d'être compliqué
pour elle en même temps elle va dans un
indice est très majoritairement blancs
dans une
dans un quartier qui n'est pas du tout
le café dans lequel elle vit et du coup
annoncé vous explique ce fait qu'elle a
deux personnalités en croquer les deux
personnes différentes ailes et l'aja
film bien comme il faut pour les blancs
et des ailes et elle même dans son
quartier et c'est compliqué à gérer
cette situation pour elle donc ce film a
avancé plusieurs points le fait pas
avoir demande d'identité propre et aussi
le bal des violences et viol a donc un
film important en film à voir et pour
revenir sur les misérables là en fait à
suit on suit trois policiers de la bac
en banlieue pareil une affaire qui
dérape et on voit à la fois la réaction
des policiers savent pas assez
d'étouffer la faire d'autres pas sont un
peu plus humain mais même du côté des
des jeunes de banlieues qui sera
impliqué la beauté de la violence et on
perd un peu son humanité aussi à ce
moment là même du côté du vert avenue
peut-être pas plus loin personne dans le
film totalement bondées totalement j'ai
donc c'était deux films l'un d'eux film
très intéressant à voir je fais ça il
nous reste deux films et j'ai été un peu
plus constructive et un peu moins
hésitante que l'an dernier je crois on
progresse tout en rappelant que je n'ai
pas de compétences particulières dans le
domaine danalyse cinématographique c'est
justement ressenti est mon point de vue
l'avant dernier film dans la catégorie
absurde
ledun de quentin dupieux il n'est pas
dans mes préférés de l'année
mais quand même il était bien et du coup
j'avais envie d'en parler donc les
acteurs sont jean dujardin et adèle pedn
et donc vous cette lecture de quoi c
c'est un film qui a une ambiance très
particulière
les couleurs déjà son trait pastel
c'était intéressant et ça se passe dans
leur paysage un peu le montagne je
suppose et les vosges
jardel un truc du genre on super sage de
jean dujardin qui est un personnage
complètement paumé dans sa vie est très
liée aussi très comment dire ingénue ne
s'est pas son rêve c'est de porter du
daim déjà et après un autre rêve qui se
développe dans film et dont je vais pas
parler il rencontrera des lendl qui on
sait pas trop si son personnage est elle
aussi complètement niaise et du coup le
sud dans son délire ou si elle est
beaucoup plus manipulatrice que ça et
est du coup c'est intéressant et on lui
c'est absurde c'est complètement absurde
et ce film a popularisé pendant un bref
temps la phrase style de malades que
j'aime beaucoup
donc regarder lieu parce que c'était
vraiment bien et on en arrive au dernier
film qui est tout récent puisque je les
ai vus
ce week end nous sommes actuellement le
24 décembre d'où le chapeau et la robe
jolie puisqu'après jeu parfait de
l'enfer le réveillon est gelée vue je
les mange dimanche et deux jours en
france est à couteaux tirés
un film américain comme il y en avait
peu c'est bien d'en mettre pas fait de
quotas donc un film de ryan johnson qui
est aussi le réalisateur de l'un des
baigneurs star wars qui soit je suis
sérieuse à ce sujet et avec plein
d'acteurs bon dedans plein d'acteurs
connus mais bon acteur principal par là
deux acteurs principaux et daniel craig
mais c'est un petit peu un film
orchestre où tous les acteurs ont leur
importance
c'est un film qui fait très dense et une
enquête une enquête sur un meurtre ou
suicide on ne s'est pas trop au début et
et un peu à la agatha christie avec
plein de personnages un enquêteur avec
un nom à consonance française ce que
rappelle un père du calcul poireau qui
vient essayer de résoudre la sphère et
les appelés en renfort par le biais de
la police et toutes les personnes
peuvent être suspecte
toutes les personnes sont pour un petit
quelque chose qui fait qu'elles sont pas
là il n'y a pas une personne
complètement gentil complètement
méchante
sauf peut-être une personne je n'en dis
pas plus et c'est très très prenant très
drôle aussi
il utilise beaucoup de deux ficelles de
ce style de film je battrai policiers
habituellement mais là c'était parfois
un petit peu pas dans la parodie mais
dans la satire du genre parfois
complètement dans le genre
ouais c'était vraiment bien vraiment
très prenants si longtemps mais on est
dans l' enquête jusqu'au bout et dans
les retournements de situation jusqu'au
bout et c'est un bon film du coup un peu
à la clau
aussi est-ce que sur la fiche ils sont
tous coloris est pour ça que je pense au
plateau tout à fait exprès d'ailleurs
sûrement et voilà eh ben du coup on en
arrive à la fin de cette liste de films
et comme d'habitude je pense qu'en
générique que je vais mettre aussi les
films les autres films que j'ai aimé
mais dont je vais pas parler les films
que j'ai pas aimé parce que comme ça que
je fous là dernier pas ou alors regarder
les autres ou vrai que j'ai mauvais goût
parce que vous les aimerez je ne sais
pas voilà je pense que je voulais bien
d'autres choses à la fin de cette vidéo
wii chronique de prof arrive je n'ai pas
encore écrit
mais il arrivera bien sûr juste après la
diffusion de time warp g jeudi met du
temps à me remettre à mes recherches à
l'écriture et tout ça et et j'ai une vie
bien remplie déjà personnellement et
aussi professionnellement certaines
choses dont je pourrais vous parler
bientôt mais pas encore donc cette année
j'ai un peu plus de mal à tenir le
rythme une vidéo par mois mais j'ai
essayé de me remettre à partir de
janvier ça sera peut-être pas toujours
des chroniques de profs du coup ce sera
peut-être des jantes obama date parce
que c'est un peu plus simple à écrire
mais je vais essayer de me remettre
correctement et
et le prochain chronique de profs
arrivera courant janvier je l'espère on
y croit et du coup voilà merci beaucoup
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu bonnes fêtes
de fin d'année à tous je pense que
moment où sortir à noël sera passée mais
peut-être pas encore le nouvel an donc
on y croit et abonnez vous partagez
d'habiter au jeu rappelle aussi que j'ai
une page tipis et lou type qui vous
permettent de financer mes vidéos soit
en regardant des pubs et donc ça nous
coûte rien soit en tenant des souhaits
du coup ça vous coûte mais c'est très
gentil parce que ça me permet de bain
devient peut vivre de ça ce qui est
toujours intéressant quand on aime cette
activité qui prend du temps et de
l'énergie
et voilà partager abonnez vous commentez
ne fait pas de commentaires sur mon
décolleté parce que c'est pas sympa est
ce que je sais qu'il y aura forcément
qu'il y en a toujours
c'est pas sympa ne faites pas ça et je
vais arrêter ça va maintenant
enfin cette vidéo je dire c'est fini
c'est fini j'ai plus rien à dire donc je
vais arrêter
alors arrêtez de parler maintenant merci
au revoir
[Musique]
donc
il
[Musique]
nous
on
m
[Musique]
écrit
où